Increase your confidence and land your dream job...
...by learning how to answer hard interview questions.
You will need preparation, communication skills, goals, a positive attitude,...
...enthusiasm, work samples and a resume.
Optional: a computer with Internet access.
Step one: Prepare for the interview by familiarizing yourself...
...with common tough questions and practicing your answers.
Searching online for sample questions will help you feel more prepared.
Step two: Talk to the interviewer about your education, work experience,...
...qualifications and goals when asked to talk about yourself.
Communicate clearly by keeping it short and to the point.
Step three: Focus on what you learned and how you wanted to achieve new goals...
...when asked why you left your last employer.
Keep a positive attitude when discussing previous employment.
Step four: Express to the interviewer that you see yourself growing with the company...
...by utilizing your knowledge and experience when asked where you see yourself in five years.
Step five: Focus on what you can improve in your work...
...and how it will become an asset to the organization you are interviewing for...
...when asked about your weaknesses.
Step six: Show your enthusiasm for the position you are applying for...
...and state that your salary is negotiable when asked about compensation.
Step seven: Focus on your unique personal attributes...
...when asked why they should hire you for the job.
Show them samples of your work and refer to your resume, and get that job.
Did you know?
Interview questions relating to health conditions, race, age,...
....marital status and gender are illegal.